à voir l'article 22 deux amendements
identiques le 63 qui le défend oui je
vous en prie mais monsieur le président
cet amendement propose que sans l'accord
explicite de l'ensemble des communes
concernées l'implantation d'un parc
éolien ne peut avoir lieu en effet les
mères se sentent souvent démunis face à
l'implantation d'éoliennes qui
rencontrent de plus en plus d'opposition
de la part de leurs administrés
aujourd'hui la vie leur avis n'est plus
que consultatif qui n'est pas acceptable
car ils sont aménageurs du territoire et
doivent avoir un rôle décisionnel sur
tout projet de construction
c'est à dire définir les conditions
acceptables pour les citoyens est
positive pour le territoire sous vous
remercier merci et le 822 2 qui le
présente
oui je vous en prie oui merci monsieur
le président madame la ministre méchante
collègues
l'objet de cet amendement est de
renforcer le rôle des élus locaux et des
populations surtout les projets éoliens
en convergence à ce qu' il vient d'être
rappelé par notre collègue il faut bien
reconnaître que durant ces dernières
années voir ces dernières semaines
encore la multiplication de ces
installations d'électricité pose de
sérieux problèmes génère parfois
d'ailleurs des conflits des conflits et
des incompréhensions
or la qualité de leur implantation
dépend de la qualité de la concertation
et dépend aussi de l'acceptation par ces
populations et des élus des projets en
question
donc l'objectif est encore une fois de
renforcer le rôle de ces élus locaux
dans l'implantation des éoliennes afin
de rendre au fond leur avis plus
déterminant quand il s'agit d'opérer ses
choix merci merci à myla commission sur
madame
oui merci monsieur le président ces deux
amendements identiques vise à renforcer
les pouvoirs de contrôle des élus locaux
sur les décisions d'implantation
d'éoliennes sur l'objectif je suis en
accord avec les amandes dans toutefois
je vous proposerai plutôt d'adopter un
autre amendement que l'on verra un tout
petit peu plus tard qui est l'amendement
862 monsieur courtial qui institue un
droit de veto de la commune pour
l'ensemble des projets et pas uniquement
ceux soumis à une enquête publique
l'amendement 860 me semble satisfaire
l'objectif porté par ces deux
amendements identiques d'une manière
encore plus large et opérante
je vous propose donc le retrait de ces
amendements au profit de 860 autrement
la vie sera défavorable à vis du
gouvernement sur ces deux amendements
identiques madame la ministre
merci monsieur le président c'est un
avis défavorable sur cette question des
implantations d'éoliennes on voit bien
les débats qui ont lieu sur lesquels je
suis absolument convaincu que nous
devons remettre un petit peu de raison
et un peu moins de passion dans la
mesure où
on ne peut pas débattre sérieusement
d'un sujet en se fondant sur des faits
qui sont inexactes ou sur sur des
sentiments c'est trop important il
s'agit de notre politique énergétique
globale c'est pourquoi nous avons en ce
moment
des mesures qui sont en train d'être
prises d'abord pour favoriser
l'acceptabilité des éoliennes dans
certains endroits il y à des endroits
notamment où il y avait des problèmes
sur la luminosité sur le balisage des
éoliennes
il y avait à une époque s'est bien
terminée maintenant un problème du des
soft des éoliennes par exemple qui
restait soudé qui restait dans la terre
qu'il n'y avait pas d'obligation
d'enlever maintenant évidemment quand il
ya du repowering on enlève les socles
des éoliennes
il y a aussi des dd obligation de
recyclage etc etc
al'inverse de beaucoup de choses qu'on
peut entendre néanmoins il y a eu des
lieux où il a pu y avoir à juste titre
un sentiment d'encerclement parce qu'il
n'y avait pas eu suffisamment de
concertation sur l'implantation de ces
éoliennes on tire des leçons de cela tu
pour essayer de concilier comme il faut
toujours essayer de le faire
nos impératifs et j'insiste bien sur nos
impératifs de dévolution de notre mix
électrique et de développement de
l'électricité en france nous avons des
besoins et aussi des impératifs de
préserver notre patrimoine et notre
notamment notre patrimoine culturel mais
aussi notre patrimoine naturel
c'est-à-dire la biodiversité qui à
laquelle je suis particulièrement
attaché pour faire cela il ya une
méthode la méthode c'est d'abord de
faire une cartographie les préfets ont
reçu une circulaire qui leur demande
d'établir une cartographie des lieux où
on peut faire je prends un peu de temps
pour répondre je serais beaucoup plus
rapide après pour les autres mais comme
ça je mets le cadre une cartographie
dents
dans chaque département pour qu'on sache
là où il est possible de mettre des
éoliennes est là où il n'est pas
possible d'en mettre
pour des raisons variées mais que mes
cumulatif bien sûr que ce soit d'abord
évidemment là où il ya du vent et parce
que ça ne sert à rien de mes dix
éoliennes là où il n'y a pas de vent là
où il n'y a pas de radars notamment les
radars militaires on a un sujet sur la
question de ces radars militaires
là où il n'y a pas de problème avec
l'aérien là où il n'ya pas aussi de
problèmes de biodiversité identifier des
couloirs par exemple de migration
d'oiseaux ou des endroits où il y a
notamment des chauves souris on sait que
les chauves souris sont très perturbés
par des éoliennes mais aussi des
éléments de patrimoine remarquable que
nous souhaitons préserver
bref tous ces éléments vont permettre
d'établir une cartographie assez
précises qui sera une aide à la décision
pour tout un chacun
ensuite et c'est l'objet de mesures qui
sont présentés dans ce projet de loi il
va y avoir une déclinaison par région de
nos objectifs de programmation
pluriannuelle de l'énergie pourquoi
parce que la programmation pluriannuelle
de l'énergie nous donne des objectifs
par type d'énergie mais ne définit pas
du tout comment ces objectifs se met en
place sur les territoires et donc ça
crée un problème tout simple c'est que
quelque part c'est ce que me disait mon
papa il disait c'est pas en lançant en
l'air l'alphabet que va retomber une
bible en fait donc c'est bien il faut
bien un moment donné une méthode pour
qu'on puisse respecter nos propres
engagements
ça permet aussi à chaque région de
prendre sa part à l'effort collectif
puisque c'est une programmation qui
concerne notre pays tout entier y'a pas
de raison que certaines régions prennent
une grosse part de l'effort et d'autres
moi c'est normal qu'ils aient une
répartition et donc à partir du moment
où nous aurons cette cartographie et où
nous aurons les objectifs région par
région ce sera plus facile après de
déterminer encore en coopération en
concertation avec les uns et des autres
là où il faut mettre des éoliennes
et là où il ne faut pas en mettre et ça
permettra aussi de donner une visibilité
dans le temps il n'y aura plus ce
sentiment que peuvent ressentir certains
de nos concitoyens d'avoir des éoliennes
qui poussent sans trop comprendre pour
d'où ça vient comment et puis est ce
qu'il va encore y en avoir d'autres
après non ce sera plus clair
je crois que c'est ça qui est important
donner de la visibilité concertée
pouvoir avancer et puis on a aussi des
éléments d'être fiscales qui sont
permises et puis dernier point je suis
très attentive à ce qu'on puisse aussi
développer la participation citoyenne au
développement des énergies renouvelables
là où ça se passe en france ça marche
très bien c'est à dire en fait nous
avons des habitants qui investissent en
fait dans les éoliennes qui est près de
chez eux et donc ils perçoivent des
revenus pendant les audiences fonctionne
c'est plus intéressant que le livret a
et ça permet en plus d'avoir une d'avoir
vraiment participation est de pouvoir
retirer des bénéfices de cette source
d'énergie qui est qui et près de chez
eux
bref c'est tout ça qu'il faut développer
quand on dit qu'il va y avoir des
communes qui vont pouvoir mettre des
droits de veto
je dis attention parce que ça veut dire
aujourd'hui il n'y a que 20 % du
territoire français qui peut recevoir
des déserts lienne c'est aussi ça le
problème moi j'essaye d'agrandir ce
périmètre parce que du coup c'est normal
que quand on a que 20 % il puisse y
avoir des endroits où on a le sentiment
d'être encerclés donc on essaye de
trouver la bonne mesure dans tout ça si
on donne des droits de veto
ça veut dire que quelque part on
n'incite pas cette concertation et au
fait qu'on trouve des solutions ensemble
un droit de veto
ça peut entraîner or dans certains
endroits ça va bien se passer un mais
dans d'autres endroits ça peut entraîner
tout simplement de du nimby c'est à dire
pas chez moi
moi je veux bien avoir de l'électricité
mais mais en gros pas chez moi et le
problème on l'a avec les éoliennes
on l'aura après avec les panneaux
photovoltaïques on l'aura avec la
méthanisation
et puis si tout ça fait que à la faim
plus personne ne veut avoir des
éoliennes on va avoir parce que
reconstruire toutes les centrales
nucléaires qu'il faudrait
pour faire face à nos besoins dans 30
ans je pense qu'on va aussi avoir des
problèmes d'acceptabilité donc je crois
qu'à un moment il faut qu'on soit tous
raisonnable et que on essaye d'avancer
c'est pourquoi je crois que trop que
d'une manière ou d'une autre donner un
droit de veto c'est toujours un danger
et qui empêche la concertation voilà
pourquoi je suis défavorable aux
amendements qui mettent en place des
droits de veto
quelle que soit leur forme je préfère la
concertation donc c'est un avis
défavorable à cet amendement est donc au
suivant ça ira beaucoup plus vite
monsieur layec mais merci monsieur le
président après avoir entendu le débat
et les propositions qui sont venus là je
propose également que nous retirions
l'amendement sous les dettes les deux
amendements et en retirer qui a plus
d'explications de vote sur des
amendements avant l'article 22 le 823
monsieur guay il est retiré avant
l'article 22 va justement le 862
monsieur consiel s'imaginer tiennent
dans cette fois ci c'est votre tour
merci monsieur le président la ministre
et le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est
qu'actuellement est l'implantation des
éoliennes pose un problème majeur un
problème d'acceptabilité ça a été dit et
ça a été répété peut-être parce que
lorsque l'on a décidé de cette stratégie
éoliennes on n'a pas suffisamment
expliqué qu'il y avait une pollution
lumineuse qu'il y avait une pollution
sonore qu'il y avait un impact sur les
couloirs de migration des oiseaux et que
dans le calcul de l'amortissement des
installations n'avaient pas suffisamment
pris en compte
le recyclage de l'éolienne elle-même
mais aussi le recyclage du béton
alors ce problème d'acceptabilité c'est
ce pourquoi l amendement et que je
présente avec un certain nombre de
collègues a été déposée il s'agit de
quoi d'abord il s'agit de
mieux établir la concertation et la
consultation avant le dépôt de
l'autorisation environnementale
le dossier doit être remis à la commune
d'implantation et à son maire nous ont
mis un délai de 1 mois de manière à ce
que le maire le conseil municipal les
associations évidemment les habitants
que le maire puisse consulter préparer
le dossier le comprendre poser des
questions et éventuellement recourir aux
services de l'état pour comprendre tout
les tenants et les aboutissants des
conséquences de l'installation de
l'éolienne c'est le premier item de cet
amendement est le second oui
effectivement c'est bien de donner un
droit de veto à la commune il faut que
ce soit le conseil municipal qui
délibère et évidemment qui mieux qu'un
conseil municipal dans une commune peut
prendre une décision de cette nature
car enfin mes chers collègues c'est
quand même bien curieux quand il s'agit
des éoliennes
on ne veut pas que la commune donne son
avis on ne veut pas qu elle délibère on
veut encore moins un droit de veto alors
que vous même sur d'autres équipements
on va évidemment parler du nucléaire
mais on peut parler de bien d'autres
vous dites à l'envi et vous répéter
qu'il faut absolument une démocratie
renforcée qu'il faut consulter plus et
qu'il faut évidemment que les conseils
municipaux soit mieux associé alors on
peut pas être pour une consultation
quand il s'agit du nucléaire et on peut
pas être contre une consultation quand
il s'agit de l'éolien il faut être
cohérent et la cohérence c'est de donner
le pouvoir au conseil municipal
bien avisent la commission madame
monsieur le président cet amendement
répond à une demande très forte de la
part des élus locaux vous l'avez rappelé
qu'ils sont souvent démunis face à
l'implantation de parcs éoliens sur leur
territoire malgré le rôle fondamental
qui jouent en matière d'aménagement les
maires réclament davantage de visibilité
mais aussi la possibilité de jouer un
rôle décisif dans ses projets
d'implantation
je note que s'agissant de l'information
des communes concernées un régime existe
déjà à l'article l100 81 28 2 du code de
l'environnement qui a d'ailleurs été
introduit au sénat par un amendement au
projet de loi relatif à l'accélération
et à la simplification de l'action
publique dite loi pacte en 2020 le
périmètre n'est toutefois pas tout à
fait identique à celui proposé par
l'amendement puisque l'article que je
viens de citer prévoit une information
de l'ensemble des communes limitrophes
nous pourrons peut-être retravailler la
rédaction en c1 paix afin de clarifier
le régime d'information des communes et
l'avis est favorable et je remercie les
collègues qui ont retiré leur amendement
au profit de celui ci madame la ministre
l'avis du gouvernement
l'avis du gouvernement monsieur le
président reste le même parce que ce que
je ne voudrais pas c'est que on se
perdent dans des débats qui sont des
débats qui ne sont pas à la hauteur de
l'enjeu et je vous renvoie à un article
que j'ai trouvé très intéressant ce
matin dans les échos qui était une
interview un entretien avec le président
de la commission de régulation de
l'énergie qui est à quelqu'un qui
connaît très très bien ses sujets et qui
pose les débats très simplement il nous
dit en gros à l'horizon 2050 puisque une
politique énergétique c'est long vous le
savez bien
à l'horizon 2050 où nos réacteurs
nucléaires se seront arrêtées
nous ne sommes pas en capacité de
construire 60 2 gigawatts de nucléaire
que ce soit pour des raisons
industrielles mais aussi d'acceptabilité
parce qu'on aura le même problème sauf
que par contre y'a pas de moratoire dans
le droit sur des conseils municipaux sur
des centrales nucléaires sur le plan
économique les énergies renouvelables
atteigne aussi le même niveau de prix
que l'électricité nucléaire historique
on aurait tort de s'en priver il faut
donc doucement baisser la part du
nucléaire et trouver des substituts
le premier substitut au nucléaire et
entend bien sûr comme l'a dit monsieur
le sénateur tout à l'heure c'est un
maîtrise de la consommation grâce à
l'efficacité énergétique croissante mais
attention au global la consommation
d'électricité va augmenter car nous
devons décarbonés le transport et le
chauffage
la deux le deuxième volet c'est la
flexibilité des réseaux jeu je ne
m'étends pas plus pourquoi l'éolien est
il incontournable parce que toutes les
énergies renouvelables ne se valent pas
l'hydrogène est aujourd'hui hors de prix
l'hydrolien également et on ne disposera
pas assez de gaz vers pour décarbonés le
gaz et produire de l'électricité il nous
faut donc faire du solaire et de
l'éolien le solaire et bon marché mais
prend beaucoup de place pour construire
l'équivalent d'un réacteur nucléaire
repères il faudrait disposer des
panneaux photovoltaïques sur
l'équivalent de 7500 terrain de football
nous allons continuer à chercher de
l'espace et poursuivre la recherche pour
augmenter la productivité mais le
solaire ne suffira pas seuls il nous
faut donc absolument développer l'éolien
la france à cinq fois moins d owlient au
kilomètre carré que l'allemagne 3,3 fois
moins que le danemark
il y encore de la place il faut que
chacun fasse un effort
je vous invite à lire le reste de
l'article qui est très intéressant donc
à partir de ce moment là nous avons nous
devons décliner nous sommes sur des
objectifs d'intérêt national ces
objectifs d'intérêt national
ils sont délimitées dans la plus haute
programmation pluriannuelle
l'énergie pour laquelle il y à une
remise à jour
je ne sais plus tout à l'heure qui a dit
que ben oui mais on a pris des décisions
il ya déjà un certain temps les choses
évoluent etc et c'est pour ça qu'il est
une remise à jour et que les
parlementaires ont obtenu à l'assemblée
nationale nous étions battus pour ça
pour que ces remises à jour se fasse au
niveau du parlement que le parlement
français et le droit de voter les
programmations pluriannuelles de
l'énergie à partir du moment où nous
votons ses programmations pluriannuelles
il faut en temps parlementaire vous en
l'occurrence que vous ayez à coeur ce
qui me paraît quand même la base c'est
que ce que vous votiez puissent être
appliquées et que l'on puisse
l'appliquer sur les territoires et il ne
faut pas qu'on se mette sur les
territoires des verrous qui vont faire
ce sera impossible d'appliquer les
politiques qui sont votées par la
représentation nationale
et c'est en ça qu'il faut qu'on trouve
la conciliation entre ce qu'on doit
mettre en place et ce qu'on met en place
sur les territoires
une cartographie c'est la reprise des
zones de développement éolien qui était
demandé par tout le monde
donc la cartographie c'est ça qu'il faut
faire et ensuite il faut faire de la
concertation
à chaque fois qu'on met un verrou on met
un point vraiment une pierre dans notre
propre jardin
voilà pourquoi je suis défavorable bien
monsieur dantec
oui madame la ministre l'a dit même en
imaginant que le p r fonctionne un prix
raisonnable ce qui est quand même très
très loin d'être démontrée on ne peut
pas réussir la transition énergétique le
développement de la mobilité électrique
sans l'éolien terrestre
c'est pas possible ce sont les scénarios
de rte qui ont été présentés la semaine
dernière ce que vous êtes nana na na na
na na
nanan il n'y a aucun scénario parce qu'à
un moment il faut être un peu sérieux et
pas sortir des arguments faux il faut
regarder un peu les chiffres il n'y a
aucun scénario de rte qui passe sans
l'éolien terrestre
ce que vous êtes en train de faire en
participant à des oppositions réelles et
que personne ne conteste c'est en fait
en train de préparer le fait que nous
allons acheter notre électricité
ailleurs que les le câble irlandais qui
va à qui arrive le fait qu'elle jnj en
commun sophie primas on a quand même
beaucoup regardez ce qu'a fait angie en
vendant suez elle j avais besoin de ces
milliards là pour investir massivement
dans les énergies renouvelables et en
premier lieu dans l'éolien
si c'est pas possible en france si c'est
pas possible en france assurera fait
ailleurs vos votes proposition me semble
totalement déclinistes d'un pays qui
n'assume plus ses stratégies qui tourne
le dos à son histoire gaulliste qui est
incapable d'avoir une politique
nationale avec des élus qui sont
totalement totalement perdu et qui vont
dans le sens du vent de ce qu'il semble
être la halle et wimbledon dit je le dis
je le dis et moi je crois qu'à un pays a
besoin d'une stratégie énergétique
là il n'y en a plus dernier point
dernier point votre truc est quand même
sacrément dangereux parce que si une
commune qui fait ses calculs en disant
en termes du fr en termes de retombées
je suis quand même preneur
elle va donc décider pour tous le grand
périmètre autour et vous croyez qu'on
crève vraiment de la cohésion
territoriale avec c'est logique là c'est
impossible et on reparlera ensuite de
référendum qui ne sont pas la bonne mais
je rappelle que les plus concernées
qu'on resserre le périmètre sur notre
dame des landes c'est le nom qui l'a
emporté bon j'ai un coup
un certain nombre d'orateurs je ne suis
pas sûr qu'on puisse voter avant la
levée de séance mais vous reprendrez
demain matin allez on a le problème
aucun problème pour moi je ne suis pas
là demain matin monsieur ça le monde ok
merci monsieur le président alors moi je
ne suis pas à d'admirateurs bea des
éoliennes effectivement chacun peut
avoir son avis sur le paysage et c'est
indéniable que une éolienne dans le
paysage ça ne passe pas inaperçu surtout
quand on est dans un paysage très
ouverte open field quand on a du bocage
des ah ça se voit moins
mais vous parler d' incohérences mais
non nous avons une cohérence
nous avons des objectifs nous voulons
nous passer du fossile et du gie cible
et nous avons donc les moyens pour y
arriver nous avons des programmes
d'énergies renouvelables qui nous
permettent d'y arriver qui arrive et
dieu 2050
ceci est possible ce ne sont pas des
élucubrations après il faut prendre les
moyens effectivement l'éolienne c'est un
moyen de produire responsable on me
parle de recyclage c'est amusant quand
même il ya beaucoup de gens qui ne se
sont pas posé beaucoup de questions sur
le recyclage des déchets nucléaires elle
a vraiment écouté je suis content de
vous entendre parler de recyclage on me
parle des communes effectivement
lorsqu'on n'entendent déconstruction de
rocade et construction de quatre voies
si chaque commune avait dû dire banon
wallemacq à deux voix elle ne passe pas
dans ma commune je pense que la
continuité n'aurait pas été
exceptionnelle en france dont un peu de
cohérence et la cohérence je pense
qu'elle est complètement de notre côté
et à un moment il faut regarder l'avenir
en face
effectivement une éolienne je vous
disais tout à l'heure en huit mois elle
a racheté sa dette énergétique
aucune source d'énergie en fait autant
ensuite une éolienne ça se monte en
quelques jours et ça se démontre à en
quelques jours
et il n'en restera rien c'est une
question de responsabilité pour les
générations futures pour nos enfants
admettons que dans le paysage ça nous
gêne aujourd'hui à un moment il faut se
dire est ce que demain je pourrais ne
pas céder et éolienne peut-être on
trouvera peut-être autre chose avec
beaucoup de sobriété et peut-être de
nouvelles rencontres scientifiques et à
ce moment là on démontre à les éoliennes
qui ne coûte rien en démantèlement parce
qu'ils sont faites avec des matériaux
pour une grande partie très nobles comme
le cuivre qui rien qu'à lui tout seul
paye le démantèlement de l'éolienne je
peux dire qu'on ne je peux assumer qu'on
ne dit pas la même chose du nucléaire
donc un peu de cohérence et la cohérence
je l'affirmé elle est notre côté eh bien
monsieur houlgate
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues on
s'aperçoit à travers ce débat que il n'y
a pas de système énergétique parfait et
que chacun a ses contraintes et je crois
qu'il faut qu'on puisse l'admettent donc
il va falloir que à travers ces
contraintes on trouve le chemin qui nous
permettent nous de satisfaire par
rapport aux besoins et notamment par
rapport aux objectifs de de la ppe
en ce qui concerne l'éolien terrestre
savoir qu' on a à peu près entre 6500 et
7000 éoliennes en ce moment et il faut
pas falloir qu'on multiplie par deux le
nombre d'éoliennes donc il va falloir
qu'on trouve entre guillemets des sites
qui vont pouvoir accueillir ce
doublement du nombre d'éoliennes
je voudrais signaler également que faut
pas qu'ils aient une confusion parce
qu'entre la puissance installée d'une
éolienne terrestre
je parle bien d'une éolienne terrestre
et et son rendement bas le rendement il
est de 20 % parce que il n'ya pas
toujours du vent alors que en éolien
offshore on peut arriver on va arriver à
des à des rendements qui sont des
rendements de 67% donc est quand même
une différence
alors ensuite quelle est la bonne
méthode et je voudrais aussi ouvrir une
petite parenthèse le scénario 100%
renouvelable tel qu'il a été élaboré par
rte c'est pas non plus le scénario idéal
parce que lui il a d'énormes contraintes
il a des contraintes par rapport à la
halle total intermittence et la
résolution de l'intermittence va faire
je suis désolé de le dire mais qu'on va
devoir rénover complètement le réseau de
distribution et on va mettre des
centaines de kilomètres de lignes haute
tension pour pouvoir équilibrer les
réseaux il faut qu'on le sache
il faut qu'on le sache alors après
comment faire moi je pense que la bonne
méthode c'est un peu oui madame la mini
c'est ce qui est en train de se faire et
de se dessiner à travers le projet de
loi que nous examinons une cartographie
une cartographie avec des objectifs
régionaux et puis
les préfets ont reçu mission également
d'identifier moi je suis tout à fait
satisfait de ce qui se passe en or en
matière d'éolien offshore où on essaie
de trouver un consensus autour de ce
qu'on appelle des zones de moins de
contraintes
et c'est à travers ces zones de moines
ou contrainte qu'on arrive par les
débats publics par la concertation par
le dialogue avec les maires avec
l'ensemble des acteurs à trouver entre
guillemets les meilleures solutions et
je rejoins ce qui a été dit tout à
l'heure il faut être extrêmement
vigilant il faut laisser la
planification faire et ne pas faire en
sorte que ce soit le privé qui impose
ses sites et qu il le fait souvent avec
une constatation un peu malsaine avec
les maires monsieur pieds noirs
monsieur le président je sais qu'il est
tard vous nous avez invité à la sobriété
en termes de prise de parole mais il ya
des choses qu'on ne peut pas laisser
laisser passer sans réagir un minimum et
messieurs chers collègues parce que
c'est un peu à fronts renversés et quand
on entend parler de stratégie en terme
énergétique de politique énergétique
pour notre pays qu'on invoque le général
de gaulle qui a été le pionnier pour le
nucléaire qu'on a laissé pendant des
années des lobby anti-nucléaire
démanteler toute cette toute cette
filière qu'on est en train de nous
expliquer aujourd'hui ci aurait pas
moyen que la convention citoyenne ce
formidable le tirage au sort des gens au
hasard qui n'a aucune compétence à la
base c'est pas moi qui le dit c'est ça a
été ça a été publiée partout que on est
au promeut comme ça là la démocratie
participative est par contre la
démocratie représentative ça n'existe
pas de quoi parlons nous aujourd'hui
c'est de donner la possibilité aux
conseils municipaux de se saisir d'un
sujet qui concerne leur territoire vous
êtes en train de nous expliquer aussi
dantec qu'aucun maire de france ne
serait capable de convaincre ses
concitoyens ses conseillers municipaux
d'abord qu'un projet éolien et bien et
bien fondées chanson sur son sur sa
ville au camer de france ce serait
capable de faire ça c'est inquiétant ça
ça veut dire qu'il ya quelque chose
d'extrêmement puissant qui se passe dans
d'autres pays vous masquer cette réalité
là moi je préfère qu'il ya une
consultation sur cette base là plutôt
que
les acharnés qui bloquent des projets
comme notre dame des landes allez allez
on se calme on se calme c'est pas la
peine de vous traiter de quoi que ce
soit c'est pas mieux pas pire des deux
côtés allez la parole est à la
présidente prima merci de rester calme
vous invectivé pas ça ne sert à rien
madame la présidente frimas et elle
seule à la parole pour une fois mes
chers mes chers collègues nous on est en
train de voilà d'avoir un débat un petit
peu surréaliste ce soir et ans
merci au nom et j'essaye de calmer les
choses
nous ne sommes pas des anti éoliens
voilà comme j'espère que vous n'êtes pas
des anti nucléaires
bon
voilà il faut un déclic libre dans les
choses et dans la peau la programmation
de l'énergie il y a de tout il ya de 50%
d'énergie nucléaire et il y à d'autres
énergies alternatives bas carbone et
renouvelables il y a l'ensemble de ces
énergies
alors qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que
veulent dire ces amendements en réalité
depuis tout à l'heure on n'a eu que ça
fait une heure qu'on a une discussion là
dessus simplement qu'il ya un problème
d'implantation et on peut être d'accord
là dessus il ya des problèmes
d'implantation il y a on a dans le
département des yvelines je me tourne
vers marco l'aide d'antoine bourg à ce
qu'on appelle la petite bosse sur la
petite beauce ont poussé des éoliennes
sans que personne ne soit au courant
d'aucun problème de programmation dont
il ya un problème de concertation donc
ça mais les élus locaux en porte-à-faux
donc qu'il y une carte qu'ils soient
élaborées moi j'aimerais bien qu'ils
soient élaborées avec les élus locaux
plutôt que directement par les préfets
j'aimerais bien que les préfets prennent
attache des élus locaux et
singulièrement peut-être que la bonne my
c'est l'échelle des scot ou c'est
l'échelle des ep c'est d'ailleurs
peut-être pas nécessairement l'échelle
de la commune et qu'on travaille en
effet sur des applications et que les
maires que les élus qui sont volontaires
pour faire des choses quelquefois un peu
difficile dans leur commune
eh bien ils puissent travailler un
schéma d'implantation qui le travaille
en concertation avec leur population et
ainsi qu'on arrive à l'aboutissement de
l'installation d'éoliennes sans recours
parce que mon dieu qu'est ce qu'on voit
aujourd'hui on voit des recours dans
tous les sens et finalement on n'avance
pas chers collègues on n'avance pas et
on en france pas aussi vite
donc voila moi je ne suis pas choqué
qu'on fasse ici la participation
représentative qu'on donne ce mandat aux
élus locaux de travailler
avec l'état avec le gouvernement dans le
cadre d'une trajectoire avec leurs
populations
ils sont là pour ça ils ont été élu pour
ça ils ont la responsabilité sont nos
devoirs
voilà donc c'est ça ce que veut dire ces
amendements mais c'est la fable est un
monsieur guay merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre mes chers
collègues on a un débat extrêmement
intéressant mais j'ai un peu de mal à
m'y inscrire ce que pour moi il ya
plusieurs problèmes dans ce qu'on
soulève mais on en est vite beaucoup
moi par exemple sur la question des
éoliennes j'ai rien dit à l'heure mais
le principal problème que nous avons
c'est qu'aujourd'hui enfin depuis un
moment nous laissons la part belle au
privé pour décider là où elle implante
non pas pour alimenter le réseau
électrique et répondre aux besoins des
usagers à son unique but de faire du
profit
et là où il peut être le plus rentable
c'est ça la question
moi si c'est l'intérêt général voilà
mais ça ça demande une maîtrise publique
de l'aménagement du territoire
j'entendais à leur planification
je viens inscrits et c'est ça la force
du modèle phrasé pendant très longtemps
y compris y compris qu'on parle de de
gaulle c'est un c'était une entreprise
publique avait monopole public et qui
construisaient des productions en
complémentarité
le nucléaire la géothermie les barrages
hydroélectriques et les énergies
renouvelables pour répondre aux besoins
des usagers
mais on a décidé que les énergies
renouvelables on descend au privé il
faisait là où il voulait et là où
c'était le plus rentable pour lui c'est
ça le problème
deuxièmement on a tous un débat là on va
l'avoir bon je voulais m'inscrire sur
l'arctique 22 et je le fais maintenant
on va avoir tout en vivant sur les
énergies renouvelables le nucléaire etc
pardonnez moi madame la ministre mais
enfin on a un projet de loi qui
s'appelle l'évitement des vrais sujets
on a tous eu un débat sur l'agriculture
alimentation sans jamais parler des
encore libre échange et là on va avoir
tout ce débat là sauf qu il
j'ai de grandes d'edf alors je sais que
c'est plus fou c'est bruno le maire
bélanger en charge du dossier
et il annonce aux syndicats qu'il faut
aller vite avant que le président m'a
chrome prend prenne la présidence de
l'union européenne dont tout ce que nous
allons débattre de là nous allons leur
est à voir en octobre et en novembre
et savoir est ce que vous allez des
manteaux les privatiser une partie des
activités d'edf notamment les énergies
renouvelables et la question des 10
et puis pour finir en 10 secondes moi je
suis pour qu'on développe les énergies
renouvelables et le scénario somme pour
sa rte d'énergies renouvelables pose
beaucoup de questions l'adie beaucoup
d'investissements dans la distribution
l'interconnexion des réseaux et il va
falloir aller plus loin et aujourd'hui
c'est pas une énergie pilotable les
énergies renouvelables dont beaucoup
d'argent sur la recherche et
développement notamment dans l'hydrogène
pour stocker l'électricité
allez on tourne on voit là je vous
remercie monsieur le président est rien
et je donne la tv avec problème monsieur
chaize oui monsieur le président un
ministre
moi je voudrais simplement réagir à tout
ce qui a été dit jusqu'à maintenant et
faire peut-être un clin d'oeil réagir
parce que je pense qu'effectivement on
est dans un débat stérile chacun et sur
ses positions et chacun apporte ses
arguments sans forcément écouter les
autres et ce que je pense très
sincèrement que ce qui manque
aujourd'hui pour qu'on ait un débat plus
serein
c'est en fait une analyse précise et je
faire un parallèle c'est pour ça que je
veux faire ce clin d'oeil avec les
travaux qui ont été faits sur le
numérique et notamment sur l'empreinte
environnementale du numérique et je
pense très sincèrement qu'on aurait tous
à gagner parce que les travaux sont
engagés au sénat par nos commissions sur
l'empreinte environnementale des
énergies renouvelables dans toute la
chaîne des énergies renouvelables ça
pourrait et pourquoi pas du nucléaire
ça pourrait utilement éclairer nos
débats et nous permettent de pouvoir
travailler plus sereinement
merci c'est le président compte ah oui
merci merci monsieur le président juste
pour répondre en fait la question elle
n'est pas antinucléaire anti éoliens ou
quoi que ce soit elle suffit d'être
d'être réaliste on voit bien que
nucléaire coûte beaucoup trop cher et
qu'on a une ppe qu'il faut la respecter
et que l'éolien est une une part pour
pour y arriver
après quand j'écoute vos débats moi
c'est vrai que je suis assez étonné
parce que j'ai l'impression que la
droite de cet hémicycle est devenu
décroissant du coup ça m'inquiète je me
dis qu'est-ce qui se passe où en sommes
nous parce que on va parler bientôt on
va parler de la question de l'hydrogène
de déplacement électrique
on va avoir de longs débats sur ces sur
ces questions là mais il me semble qu'il
faut du coup d'électricité il faut de
l'énergie donc il va falloir quand même
réfléchir à comment on produit cette
électricité et si on est réaliste si on
regarde le coût des différents moyens de
produire de l'énergie bon se voit bien
que l'éolien il à hilla il a sa part et
puis vous parlez de je crois que c'était
fabien gay qui dès qu on est en train de
faire il ya une paire un part belle au
privé mais évidemment évidemment et
c'est ça le problème
sauf que quand je regarde ces
amendements c'est exactement ce que vous
êtes en train de faire c'est à dire que
de donner la main qu'à une seule commune
qu'est ce que vont faire les opérateurs
mais ils vont dîner entre communes ils
vont faire de la concurrence entrée
commune et c'est exactement ce qui s'est
déjà passé et là où il ya des problèmes
là où on a des champs éoliens qui n'ont
pas été gérée qu'est ce qui s'est passé
c'est des opérateurs qui sont allés voir
certains conseils municipaux qui
l'auront divo terrain jouent les achète
tant qu'ils auront promis monts et
merveilles et voilà le résultat est ce
que vous êtes en train de proposer c'est
encore pire de ce qui s'est passé
donc la solution bien sûr qu'elle est de
reprendre la main qu'elle est d'aller
vers un service public de l'énergie
parce qu'on en a besoin de réguler
qu'elle est bien sûr une question de
planification et le fait de
cartographier il me semble qu'on a une
ppe qui est très clair qui pose les
choses
bah métaux l'once mettons là sur une
carte et cette carte on peut la
développer il a été par les despotes je
pense qu'effectivement ça fait une
échelle particulièrement intéressante de
réfléchir à la celle de scott sur la
répartition des différentes moyens de
production d'énergie et là oui on peut
avoir une vraie concertation
parce qu'avoir une concertation allait à
l'échelle d'une commune je suis désolé a
changé au lien il a un impact bien
au-delà de la simple comme une pitié
bien alors il y reste
madame la rapporteure quand même pour
boucler alors beaucoup de choses
intéressantes ont été dites et je
rejoins un certain nombre d de réflexion
qui ont qui ont été évoqués mais je vais
rebondir sur la dernière remarque de
guillou de notre collègue guillaume
gontard lorsqu'il dit que à la droite de
l'hémicycle y aurait des gens des
collègues qui serait dès que je ne sais
plus quelle était l'expression voilà
alors moi je crois qu'en fait on se
trompe totalement la de débats je ne
peux pas je ne peux pas accepter ce
genre de propos je reviens simplement un
autre amendement le 860 que nous sommes
censés voter pour lesquels on prend
beaucoup plus de temps que nécessaire et
j'ai envie de dire en réalité tout ce
que vous dites moi j'ai l'impression que
en réalité vous êtes vous représentez
des collègues qui sont très méfiants
vis-à-vis de ceux qui sont censés
représenter
moi je trouve ça quand même assez
étonnant puisque en réalité
cet amendement là ce dont il s'agit
précisément c'est tout simplement de de
faire des élus locaux des parties
prenantes en réalité dans la décision
n'est même pas en train de dire si on va
mettre des éoliennes au nord au sud à
droite ou à gauche on est en train juste
de pouvoir donner un petit peu plus de
pouvoirs aux élus locaux
donc je pense qu'il faut remettre il
faut remettre le débat à sa juste place
donc matin très simplement président
j'aimerais qu'on puisse voter cette
affaire j'aurais commencé entame et on
aura d'autres occasions et moi je
souscris totalement la proposition de
doute le collègue patrick chaize je n'ai
aucun souci il y aurait d'autres
occasions il ne reste qu'un peu vu le
1200 amendements
donc je mets au voit maintenant le 860
avec un avis favorable de la commission
défavorable du gouvernement pied pour le
lever clairement le doigt d'un côté ou
de l'autre
parce que de tous
parce que seuls 17
qui est contre
il est adopté
[Musique]